[Music]  you shut your mouth my boys goddamn face  hmm how dare you how dare you how dare  you come into my home and uncork all  over Jesus of Nazareth and all the other  Jesus's who died on the cross and even  the ones who didn't how do these are  kind generous men and they've come to  celebrate their day my day  Tina our day and you come in here and  disrespect them they are gods for God's  sake their sons are their men who walk  the streets they shake hands they take  shits Oh what I'm doing here is of no  concern to them this is your day love  always has been always will be  just don't try to tell me that they all  worship you I know they don't I'm not a  fool no you're not I am an old one  you  you